[Applaudissements]
tout canal encore de nous demander à
nous de nous occuper des amuse-bouches
pour les gens qui vont remettre les
César moi c'est pas possible je suis en
prière autre chose à enfin
bonsoir les bonnes poires
Jérôme Commandeur qu'est-ce qu'il a
commandé qu'est-ce qu'il a commandé
comme Facebook
ça fait déjà rire alors qu'est-ce que tu
as acheté ah bah rien attends parce
qu'il nous demande ils disent prenez
quelque chose on vous remboursera on
sait comment ça finit j'ai utilisé mes
restes c'est sûr que c'est encore bon
bon
tout va bien tu as toujours deux
semaines de vacances
tu vois sur le cheminée là
j'aimerais bien te voir sur ma cheminée
[Musique]
voilà donc on a fait tout on a fait tout
le monde c'est tout on est super
Isabelle Adjani
oh et le Jamel alors lui de l'époque ça
serait le je dirais plutôt non
le cinéma
la dernière fois que tu allais voir un
film un peu exigeant en salle il y a
dis-moi la vérité c'était quand le
dernier c'était les sous-doués voilà tu
te rends compte là on est 0 zéro culture
la géante attrape- car de Salinger je
l'ai pas je dis Partouche j'ai lu je
l'ai pas lu j'ai acheté le disque pour
aveugle toute façon on est pas invité à
cette soirée je vais te dire je suis
sorti tout de voile dehors on est pas
invités au cinéma
en Var on va aussi au cinéma
on sort on peut vraiment frimer pour de
vrai qu'est-ce que j'ai reçu
tu sais tu peux trouver
une épopée en même temps là là j'en ai
pris plein de Mireille